- Hey, c'mon in!
(bouncy keyboard music)
Yeah, push and
believe, you got it.
- So Mike you're in Boston,
If you wanna get comfortable,
take the jacket off,
look at me.
- I like the jacket, I'm
going for the single dad look.
- Are you a single father?
- No I just like
portraying the illusion.
- Do you have a
significant other?
- Yeah I do, I
have a girlfriend.
- Where did you guys meet?
- The internet.
- Is that a club?
- Yeah.
- Where is that?
- Desperation.com,
ineedthis.org.
- You do poetry.
- Yeah, I'm a recovering
slam poet, eight years sober.
- Are you gonna go
back to your roots
for this comedy special?
- I do some rhyming.
- Can you rhyme on the spot?
I know they say comedians,
like do a joke for me,
and they go, don't
ever make me do a joke.
- I could do, yeah yeah.
- Okay so you can do the poetry.
- So I'm Mike Lawrence,
I'm in this hotel,
this conversation
is awkward as hell.
I don't know where it's going,
and I don't know how it'll go,
let's be honest, this
poem fuckin' blows.
- You think this is
an awkward interview?
It's different.
- No, no, no, it's just,
I was just going with the.
- You're going with it!
Let me try one.
Hanging out in Boston,
doing what I do,
drinkin' Dunkin' Donuts
with with a morning dew,
get out of my bed,
stretch and do that,
call my little mother,
she won't call me back,
jump into the shower,
scrub my little body,
stare in to the mirror,
just like everybody,
I said body twice, that's
a thing you don't wanna do,
when you're doin' a
poem like a haiku.
Yes! Push and
believe, you got it.
- What I love is that that
started off as a slam poem
but you slowly
became more and more
like the lead
singer of the B-52s.
- Oh I turned in to--
- I got me a car, it's
as big as a whale.
It really became
like, 'you're what?!'
PoetiC.
- Y'know you're talking
about Fred Schneider, y'know,
I get that comparison
on occasion,
I am 10% gay, I'm open
about it, I went to Bangkok,
I pushed it to the limit,
anything you wanna
open up about?
- Yeah, I uh, I dated a dude
for three weeks in college
and dumped him because he
gave me the worst hand job
that I'd ever gotten in my life.
They're supposed to be
good at that, right?
Like that's the reason
you're with another dude,
'cause he knows how to touch
stuff, it was horrible,
it was like if King Arthur
had had Parkinson's when
he pulled out Excalibur.
That's how my dick felt.
It was painful and I was
just like, I can't do this.
And the sad thing was,
this was at Thanksgiving
after he had introduced
me to his family,
came out to 'em and said
this is the guy that I love.
- Wow.
I did, I, it was not in the bio.
- I didn't know
who I was, y'know,
so I was like, I'll try
this, this sounds fun.
- I feel like we're connected,
we've been too far apart,
let's angle it and get closer.
Michael thank you.
- Yeah how's it going?
- I want you to
open up, and say,
'Brody, I'm there, I'm
comfortable with my gayness.'
- I was gay in the same way
that Michael Jordan
was a baseball player.
- Are you a baseball fan?
Maybe that's something
we could connect on.
- Oh, no, no, no, I
don't like any sports.
- You don't like sports.
- No.
- Do you exercise?
- Are you depressed?
- Yeah.
- Do you think exercise
will help your depression?
- No.
- Michael.
- Yes.
- I've been where you're at.
I've been depressed,
I've been on medication,
I've been under
doctor's supervision,
and what they tell me is,
exercise is the way to go.
Will you do that
with me right now?
- Yeah.
- Let's do it.
Yes, we're exercising,
we're pushing,
I'm here with Mike, how do
you feel right now Mike?
- Uh this is so uncomfortable.
- You'll push through it,
the depression is fading.
- We're going to the
love shack, baby.
- Oh we're back to that,
how dare you call me Schneider.
You got it, Mike Lawrence,
Steven Brodiy
Stevens, exercising,
you got it, see us on
Comedy Central very soon.
Click.
Like.
Subscribe.
Click, and like it on Facebook.
Push, believe.
What a great video,
I'm glad you liked it.
Woo!